everybody everybody always wants to
think everything's either dead or alive
it's not that binary I remember I
couldn't touch them too far
but when vine can't listen back in the
back in the back in bed you would have
loved to be on TRL right did he build
this whole [ __ ] thing on TRL now you
don't want to be on TRL because
everything exists let alone anybody
watching it so the rule vine would have
been amazing I wish you was a number-one
artist son by not even artists like
person you know why you'd be making 40
million dollars a year right now because
you would have leveraged off that you
see where I'm going
everybody's so obsessed with is this
going to be around I don't care this to
be around out there right now is the
radio station me around yes
no who gives a [ __ ] tell me where
everybody's attention is the streets
where it's underpriced
listen I want a TV show we all go ahead
to make crazy we say under fire you tell
them our attention circle so attention
where's under what I call under price
attention Instagram influencers
if you take all 300 million Americans
and you ask them to sell this bottled
water and they had unlimited budget
everybody had a million dollars how
would they sell it
I believe that 90% of Americans would
make a TV commercial or do a billboard
well that's some [ __ ] correct what I
would do my money is I would give it to
a bunch of influencers on Instagram and
I would make one or two great videos for
Facebook three minutes long and that's
what I was doing that exactly what do
they call the residences doing like 90
you know what a video will make that
anita guha fingers like they drive and
correct
so says first you know what it is you're
under priced and make addition of course
because just with me my book my book
sells a hundred thousand copies in a
week I'm making them money they give me
a three million dollar advance I'm happy
because I'm using them as a bank reason
the biggest of the bank right you give
me advance upfront but let the label
that's all it is that's all it is that's
all by the way I'm moving out of the
bank that's all it is that all of it
that's all it is
so what I do is I hear only about them I
only care I love you about Miranda I
only care about King David I only care
about Nikolas I only care about Bala I
only care about that because $35 better
matter right because they're the
attention arbitrage and that's why I
give them so much love and that's why I
give all my business advice away for
free because I want to be more valuable
to them and they are to me right and if
I'm more valuable to them than they are
to me then I can get all of them I'm
Gary Vee ah Gary Vee ah boom I fly away
I need Zara I'm sorry mama boo believe
it
if that'll slow down my gun